Virginia State Police say a
twelve-year-old girl who was abducted at
Reagan National Airport is believed to
be in extreme danger Jin Jing ma was
visiting the u.s. from China she was
last seen at the airport yesterday
morning but it took 8 hours for police
to issue an Amber Alert Jan Crawford is
at Reagan National Airport outside
Washington gen good morning
well good morning so Jin Jing was with a
tour group they had been sightseeing in
New York City and here in Washington DC
and they were heading to the west coast
and before they got to security she told
the group she needed to go the bathroom
and apparently it was thought Tom asked
they were going through security that
the group noticed her missing because
the age of the child this is a very
serious incident police say this
surveillance photo shows Jin Jing MA
moments after she was abducted about
8:15 a.m. on Thursday investigators say
that's Jin Jing on the right
her abductor on the left she is believed
to have left the airport with an unknown
middle-aged Asian female that Asian
female is described as 5 2 to 5 5
weighing 130 pounds Huck ler says the
abductor helps you in gene change
clothes before the pair exited the
airport's Terminal see through the
arrivals level that's when they got into
a white Infiniti SUV with New York
license plates before driving off we do
believe that there is a male subject
driving the vehicle that the child left
him shortly before ma disappeared police
say another surveillance photo shows Jin
jeans abductor arriving at the airport
with a male suspect Cutler says Jin Jing
may have gone with her abductor
willingly the child appears to have left
without any force she entered the
vehicle without any force but that does
not release any of our concerns now a
witness said he may have seen her
abductor meet up with her in New York
and actually hand her some food the
Virginia State Police the FBI the center
of the National Center for Missing and
Exploited Children are investigating and
they're also looking to contact her
guardians in China Anthony I hope they
find her all right Jenn thanks